you guys put all these squashes on here
and then you were like this is an option
because this isn't even close to a
squash you don't know your name
i don't even know it's my name
hey guys it's me jasmine i know i'm
usually on the other side of these
challenges but today i'm giving katie a
taste of her own medicine i've been
planning every detail of this since the
last episode we even had her film her
intro that she usually does for these
videos if this is your first time here
we take a recipe we put it through
google translate for example we go from
english to vietnamese to haitian creole
to croatian to finnish and a bunch of
other languages and finally back to
english to give us this hilariously
altered recipe now this is the part
where she's gonna like give me the
recipe and she has no idea what's coming
so let's go are you ready i'm so scared
okay new recipe it's gonna be a fun one
what
actually
today is it's your turn no
what kelly what
thanks guys thanks this is your fault
you started you started it you didn't
know you said you stopped the comments
it's my fault
i deserve this i just admit okay can i
look whenever you're ready all right
la la glory
i like how powerful this sounds and
musical la la glory okay first step of
la la glory peel one pound squash then
small shape
sorry this is hard oh my god how did you
not laugh
okay i see a lot of squash what is this
this is a coconut like a tiny coconut oh
my god
there's so many squashes on the table
and then there's this thing i don't know
i'm gonna open it up just to see what it
is
should i not eat this raw no no
am i going to die
is this taro
no
how do you do this jasmine there's
squash i'm just like i'm drawn to the
spaghetti squash
do not i haven't even done step one yet
i'm gonna peel this do i do a pound of
these and then dice it it's working with
something i've never worked with before
i'm like
did i choose wrong if i leave these
brown spots will i die no
okay hey
well don't just let me know we're not
gonna die okay i'm dicing it to make
them small shape i'm just gonna keep
cutting and peeling and chopping until i
get a pound so i have a pound i have
rinsed them i'm gonna move on to the
next step step two
sauna
you just
sauna facial for about 40 minutes until
the vegetation is widespread press too
sticky too sticky avoid leaving a dose
[Laughter]
sauna facial steam steamed and we're
steaming them we're steaming it we're
steaming it
who are you we don't know this katie
this is the katie that wants to get it
right but it's also so terrifying she's
making every problem she just laughs to
encourage herself
um there's no water oh there is water
put in the water giving myself a root
facial because this is some kind of root
i think should you just go in the water
just inside
i'm putting it in the water because i
don't think that it's in the basket like
potatoes we're gonna do this till it's
it's tender and then drain the water is
that the adults the adults is the water
i'm just gonna boil it and then i'm
gonna touch it when it's stopped
why did you say it like that i'm gonna
take a look we've waited 40 minutes
see if they're soft yep okay they're
nice and soft like a mashed potato i'm
gonna strain this guy
sauna facial right now
it's getting kind of purple so i'm gonna
add this to a bowl it said leaving no
adults behind
i am just going to mash it it said press
the sticky to the sticky so i think
press the sticky to the sticky and then
leave no lumps it's going to be super
smooth guess what i see
see a potato masher i'm feeling good
feeling like this is the way it should
be going this smells good step three add
half a teaspoon salt half a cup sugar
third cup grease and stir fantastic it
is fantastic it's just so good it's such
a confident recipe and i feel like i
need to take its confidence
i think that half a teaspoon of salt
seems right because you know it's not
too much salt half a cup of sugar oh i'm
gonna go granulated sugar i just feel
like with this i wouldn't want powdered
sugar and it would be very like dry
it would make your mouth go nice
okay and then a third cup grease is it
just oil not olive oil not gonna bake
with olive oil it has too much of flavor
i think it's vegetable oil or is it
butter
it's fantastic butter would be fantastic
i think it's vegetable oil that's a
third cup this kind of seems almost too
oily now oh god did i make a wrong turn
the oil seems really wrong it seems like
it should have been butter seems like
butter would have been fantastic
step four add flour medium heat
in those 15 days however bread grab the
cup and hide
what am i reading oh am i gonna put this
over heat and it's gonna be like a like
a choux pastry and then grab the cup and
hide it remove it from the heat oh no
there's cornstarch here and that's like
a flour sort of tapioca flour you guys
i'm gonna put this in first don't even
know what flour i'm gonna do with it
getting hot i'll just have to make a
decision and that's what i'll do okay
what if this
is the flour the mixture is the flour
and i don't add flour and i cook off the
moisture like you would a choux pastry
i'm not gonna add anything not
cornstarch not flour cook this until a
lot of the moisture is gone and it's
like kind of a stickier more like a
dough texture and that's my bread so 15
minutes i'm going to say because 15 days
seems too long yeah i don't want to stay
here for 15 days
this guy is looking pretty much like a
mash we've got most of the moisture out
and it's pretty thick so now i'm gonna
set this aside and move on to the next
step step five prepare the dough white
two cup flour half a teaspoon salt a
quarter cup sugar the okay whole in
order to be fulfilled two cup flour i
don't think i can go wrong with doing
normal flour boom two cup
flour
half a teaspoon salt that seems right
and then a quarter cup sugar
i think granulated sugar because
powdered sugar i don't know i don't bake
with it in my doughs very often quarter
cup a quarter cup sugar let me just mix
this together maybe okay the hole is
mixing it step six add a quarter cup
coconut and a quarter cup water stir
stir
when the pasta withers add water at once
so the dough comes mingling briefly
recommend the competition
is there coconut oh there's coconut
cream there's coconut milk coconut oil
oh my god oh my god oh my god there's so
many options right now i have to just ah
i'm gonna use the oil jasmine how did
you do this ever and be okay at the end
of this this is traumatizing who said i
was okay
i traumatized who said i didn't cry on
the way home
you always did so well though it's less
about the result you know it's about the
journey it's about the journey the
journey
boom
just gonna go
full tilt i don't like the water going
in i don't like it
guys sorry when the butt add water at
once so the dough is comes a mingling i
guess you add water to pasta dough this
isn't pasta dough okay and then i stir
stir stir if it's not wet enough when
the pasta withers add water at once i
don't know if you have to add it so
quickly the dough is mingling so it
becomes friendly with itself this is too
dry so i'm going to add a little bit of
water maybe it is a savory dish with and
the mash root was oh my god am i making
stuff ravioli with like and that this is
what i've done and i put coconut oil in
this is that what's happening
so i'm gonna wrap it in saran and let it
briefly recommend the competition i'm
gonna briefly let it rest and move on to
the next step
step
seven make a bright bread connect you
one and a quarter cup flour and half a
teaspoon salt in a separate bowl
separate plate i'm gonna just use
tapioca flour i'm gonna do a quarter cup
of it
and then we i'll find out shortly if
this was a huge mistake half a teaspoon
salt in a separate bowl separate plate i
need to do more i need to do a lot more
i think should it be powdered sugar what
the hell am i making step eight add six
tablespoons of melted abbreviated form
and one tablespoon oil vegetable oil red
purple no bread food purple food
this is not right
[Music]
it could be i don't have experience
making bread with tapioca flour it could
be good it could be bad i'm gonna go for
it because i've already started so
i'm just gonna keep going so add six
tablespoons of melted abbreviated form
and one tablespoon oil vegetable oil is
it six tablespoons
butter
and then one tablespoon
shortening or vegetable oil i'm gonna go
melt this and i'll be right back
six tablespoons melted butter you know
you can't go wrong with butter even if
i'm wrong it feels right i am gonna do a
tablespoon of shortening okay red purple
food coloring ah ah colors okay taro
bread is purple if i'm thinking purple
desserts like i'm gonna go with purple
because i'm worried about adding the red
and making it too dark
well my mess i'm gonna just mix this
together sorry i'm gonna go gently
gently i'm nervous i'm so nervous guys
it's pretty i mean i like purple anyways
purple is my mom's favorite color it's
my favorite color too purple's your
favorite color
this is strange but exciting okay let's
keep going with la la glory step
nine split the dough into ten equal
parts and sleep for 20 seconds in dial
ten equal parts i'm gonna just make it
like a log and then cut it into ten
pieces what am i making this is like the
texture of what this is like i i don't
maybe it's right but i think i've really
i've really done it bad and then let
these rest is what i think but i don't
know why we would let them rest i think
just rest for 20 minutes step
10 phone a temperature of 350 table okay
i think that is baked at 350 degrees but
i do not know how long
preheat
a temperature at 350 but i don't bake
anything yet yes i'm gonna go with
preheated oven at 350. so perfect yup
okay great let's keep going step 11.
roll a piece of white flour into a ball
and press down to get real round the
purple substance is wrapped as a ball
don't forget to seal
flour this guy i think this is the dough
i'm gonna separate this into ten equal
parts great okay i don't want these to
dry out i think
so i'm gonna
i don't and it's like how round just i
guess enough to wrap around these balls
i've made and wrap that into a wall
don't forget to seal seal seal seal this
in am i making a dumpling
this is not a thing that is a thing
that's so cute it's cute it's cute it
looks almost like a pierogi can i do one
more let me do another one this is not
real
the only thing is like why would they
want it to be real round and then i make
it like that i guess because that's like
a half moon
stuff it i could make one that's like
sealed like a ball and pinched at the
top
like a dumpling what if i just do all
different shapes and then what do you
like better
you know what this is
oh
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna go buns because they're
cuter to me right now that's what i'm
doing i'm gonna make 10 of these little
puppies all right step 12 throw the ball
of flour into a long oval and then press
it into a spiral throw the throw the
ball
throw the flower throw maybe his press
into a long oval and then press into his
spiral oh wait okay oh wait oh wait okay
okay okay oh wait okay okay oh wait
i'm scared okay a spiral so then i'm
thinking i'm making like a lot i'm
making it i'm gonna roll it up into a
spiral why am i doing that
there's no confidence here is that a
spiral great okay okay so do i i'm just
going to repeat this 10 times and then
i'll move on to the next step step 13
turn the dough 90 degree again and again
i left a seam at the bottom la la glory
has a personality like there's a first i
left a seam at the bottom la la glory is
here okay uh turn the dough 90 degrees
and again at like a right angle
but leave the same
at the
turn the 90 degrees it was very bad at
geometry 90 degrees it's a right angle
right
90 degrees
that's like 145 just fyi that's like a
one point
turn it up to swirl to repeat and two
become two pieces of dough what
is going on here
what if 90 degrees is like
doing this
and then turn it to stuff to swirl and
repeat i feel like maybe like maybe
you're supposed to spiral it and then
hold it and then leave a seam at the
bottom
don't you feel like you're like blacking
out yeah i feel like i'm blacking out
like i now
step 16 to add a tablespoon of the city
from the mingling of the leaven out of
the midst of the taro pace i'm always
around and closed it is a poem i think
i'm gonna take a tablespoon so this is
taro i think was i i think i'm right i
think in the city mingling i'm gonna
roll it up into a ball we're always
around and closed
[Music]
i find myself i don't know if this is
right but these guys are really cute
time to move on to the last step step 17
place membrane on trophy plate only when
they humbly twirl and boil for 30
minutes
boiler bake oh i preheated the oven at
350 degrees i'm gonna bake these guys
do they go together do they touch are
they are they friends i'm gonna go bake
these for 30 minutes or i'm gonna check
them and make sure that they're brown
they're not brown how do you know when
these are done
okay
the babies are out of the oven
they look interesting like they look
good but they just look a little strange
a little too hard let's read the last
step step 18 give permission to new
cookies and have fun alone
what would you like me for enjoy one
have fun a lot that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna plate these guys i'm assuming
these are the cookies i'm giving them
permission and alone i'm gonna eat these
by myself okay la la glory
i wanna see what uh this should have
looked like
la la glory is coming in in its original
form
[Music]
all right open your eyes
[Music]
it just
looks so much better the spiral it's a
real spiral how did they get that they
kind of feel about the same these are so
much cuter
it's okay la la glory they're so pretty
i love this spiral is it taro
it's a thousand layer taro moon cake
okay i'm gonna try this i'll try one let
me see
[Music]
are you okay
it doesn't look bad it looks pretty
delicious there's so much choppy on the
flower there's no moisture left in my
mouth
my god it's like sweet and it's not like
terrible but there's just so much starch
mmm but the filling is good let me taste
how it should really taste oh these are
just so much smaller too
much better i'm gonna come taste yeah
you can come try one
what's good what are you talking about
oh you know it has so much charge around
it
don't lie
[Laughter]
kelly did you just bite that you can't
chew it's it's like taking all the
moisture
oh i'm joking
this is not good
i also stole the recipe we were supposed
to do today so jasmine you're gonna get
back in the hot seat keep leaving us
comments and letting us know how else
you want us to
make justin's life miserable and not
mine all right bye guys
bye
[Music]
you